esta nueva oleada de protestas en Irán
representa un gran reto sin duda para la
seguridad de la República islámica el
velo ha sido un tema de debate desde el
comienzo de la Revolución han habido
muchos momentos en que las mujeres y los
hombres han salido a protestar por la
imposición de un vestir islámico que
obliga que todas las mujeres llevemos un
velo y que vamos realmente tapadas
Especialmente con colores oscuros sin
embargo esta nueva movilización está
liderada por jóvenes que han perdido el
miedo ayer veíamos jóvenes hombres y
mujeres los hombres decían que venían a
defender a las mujeres y las mujeres
quitándose el velo alzándolo y pidiendo
por justicia y por libertad y por la
libertad de poder utilizar lo que ellas
quieren y también contra Esa llamada
policía de la moral que ha dañado la
seguridad en las calles de Teherán y las
grandes ciudades del país desde el
comienzo de la Revolución islámica
deteniendo a las mujeres Simplemente
porque no se visten como quieren las
autoridades pero un gran reto que
representa para la República islámica
también está en el kurdistán iraní de
donde era originaria maxa allá han
surgido protestas desde el mismo momento
de su entierro el pasado viernes se han
visto movilizaciones populares como no
se veían desde antes lo que representa
un gran reto porque esta es una zona
empobrecida una zona donde el gobierno
tiene muchísimo temor por movilizaciones
es una población que está inconforme con
lo que le da el gobierno de Teherán y
hemos visto gran represión haya muerto
al menos tres personas según una
organización de Derechos Humanos